your Majesties your Royal Highnesses
ladies and gentlemen distinguished
guests friends the other day suddenly
out of the blue while we were talking
about something completely different my
partner
Dorothy my friend and companion burst
out as followers on the other hand she
said on the other hand how proud your
mother would have been what a pity
she isn't still alive and your father -
how proud they would have been of you
even prouder than of my son the doctor
I said even proud of them of my son the
professor even prouder if my mother was
still alive I said she would be ninety
nine and a half she would probably have
seen all dementia she would not know
what was going on around her but of
course I missed the point
Dorothy was right my mother would have
been bursting with pride my son the
Nobel Prize winner and for whom anyway
do we do the things that lead to Nobel
prizes if not for our mothers
mommy mommy
mommy mommy I won a prize that's
wonderful my dear now eat your carrots
before they get cold why must our
mothers be 99 and long in the grave
before we can come running home with the
prize that will make up for all the
trouble we have been to them too Alfred
Nobel 107 years in the grave and with
the foundation that's faithfully
administers his will and that has
created this magnificent evening for us
my heartfelt gratitude to my parents our
sorry I am that you cannot be here thank
you